as well
in the schools of public health in the
school of management and
also i'm a committee chair for governor
lamont and he's reopened work here in
canada
good morning my name is luciana borio
i'm currently at agent health
a not-for-profit strategic investment
firm that focuses on technologies for
national security
i specialize in complex public health
emergencies and medical countermeasures
including vaccines
i worked for many years at the student
drug administration
and most recently at the national
security council staff
and i'm looking forward to supporting
you and working with this terrific team
thank you dr greg
good morning president-elect and vice
president-elect and harris
such an honor to see you i am right i
served in the us department of health
and human services
as a deputy assistant secretary for
preparedness response
i was also the director of the
biomedical advanced research and
development authority known as pardon
i've worked in public and private
sectors both domestically
and internationally
you